パンっ！(机を叩く音)
おい！みんな！すき家は好きか！？
俺は…
大好きだ！
すき家に行くといろんなメニューがあると思うんですけども、
みなさんは何を頼みますか？
僕、最近はもうマグロ丼しか頼んでないんですけども
すき家には裏メニューというものがございます
ネットで調べばちょちょいのちょい！
普通にね、もうネットでね、
「すき家 裏メニュー」って調べたら、
…みたいなサイトが出てくるんですよ
で、これを見ると、
様々な裏メニューがあるみたいでございます
おっと、
勘違い、しないでくれ
俺はただ、
ネットの情報を、
見ただけさ
という訳で、真実味が無いから分かんないんですけども
それを今回確かめようという動画でございます
すごいよ！なんかね、
…とかは有名なんですけども、
なに、トッピング全部乗せとか
パッと見ねぇ、
これは無いんじゃねぇかみたいな裏メニューもあるんですよ
今回このネット上に上がってるすき家の裏メニューが
ホントにできるかどうかっていうのを、
バシッ！(胸を叩く音)
あ…待って、
あばらが折れた…
この僕が、責任を持って、
調査していこうと思います
ありそうな裏メニューも普通にあるんで、
明らかにこれは無いだろみたいな裏メニューがあれば
ちょっと頼んでみたいと思います
では行こう！
スタスタスタ！(階段を降りる音)
ドン！(扉にぶつかる音)
あぁ！…(痛がるはじめ)
シュシュー(シートベルトを締める音)
ガタ！(レバーを引く音)
ブンブーン！ブンブンブンｂ！
(エンジン音を再現するはじめ)
ガシャ(ドアを閉める音)
ドン！(ドアを閉める音)
はじめ＜あ、お持ち帰りなんですけども、
店員＜はい
なんか、裏メニューみたいなやつを頼んでみたくて、
はじめ＜あ、無い…
はじめ＜あ、なるほど分かりました
店員＜はい
はじめ＜あ、分かりました
はじめ＜じゃあちょっと、探してみます
店員＜はい
はじめ＜すいません…
ポコポコ♪
う゛ぁ゛っ…
はい、ただ今という訳で、すき家行ってきました
えぇ…結果から言いましょう
ズバリ、
裏メニュー、ていうものはほぼ…
無かった！
なんか夜中に行って、店員さんもすごい暇そうだったんで
ちょっと聞いてみたんですけど、
お持ち帰り、ホントにあの、
お持ち帰りのメニューに書いてあるやつしかダメらしくて、
ホントにある裏メニューっていうのは
まっkあの…
キング牛丼とか、あとキングカレー、あとキング豚丼とか
キングシリーズは
ちゃんと、裏メニューとして存在するらしいんですけども、
それ以外のなんかネットに乗っている
裏メニューっていうのは
基本的に無いらしいです…
いやいや、怒ってる…
おいやや、怒ってる訳じゃないです
怒ってる訳じゃないんですけども、
と思って…
やっぱこう、裏メニューって聞くとこう
テンション上がっちゃうんで、
なんかもっとヤベェのとかあったら
嬉しいかったなとか思ったんですけども、
まぁでも、それ以外にもなんか
ネットでいろんな情報があったので、
実際にすき家に行ってちょっと出来そうだなと思った
…みたいな、
こういう頼み方もあるんだぜ、
みたいなのをちょっと何個かやってみたので
参考にしてください！
どうぞ！
えぇ、まず一つ目、
みなさん、三種のチーズ牛丼食べますか？
うめぇよなあ
三種のチーズ牛丼旨いんですけども、
あれの弱点としては
こう…
…ってなっちゃって、
なんか、上手くごはんにチーズが掛かんないと
っていう事を思った人居ると思いますよ！
こんな裏ワザがあったんだ
ホントにしょうもない裏ワザなんですけども、
あの実は、チーズ牛丼頼む時に、
チーズを下にしてくださいって言ったら、
ごはん、チーズ、牛肉になります
パッと見ただの牛丼に見えるんですけども、
これ、牛肉の下にチーズが乗ってます
すなわち！
ごはんに溶けたチーズが見事に絡まり合って、
まるでリゾットみたいになっているという
あの！、
チーズにごはんの方が
なんかリゾットみたいになって美味しいかった、と思います
もう、チーズ牛丼頼む人、
今度からこれにした方がいんじゃねぇかなってぐらい、
まとまりがあった気がしました
そして次！
これ、なんだと思いますか？
そう…
だく盛りって言って、
こう、牛丼頼んだ時に汁…
ちょっとあると思うんですけども、
その汁をお店の限界レベルまで上げたら、
そして次はこちら、牛丼なんですけども、
頼む際に、ネギだくと言ったらこうなりました
もう、ほぼ肉がないっていう…
最高にヘルシーだね！
で、この2つに関しては、
やってくれる店舗とやらない店舗があるらしいので、
僕、これやってくれなかったので、2店舗目、
他のお店まで行ってやってもらいました
あざす！
そして、
なんか裏メニューっていうのは無いんですけども、
あの…要するに、
すき家にあるもので組み合わせて、
売っていないメニューを作る…のを裏メニューっていう
ゆい方もするみたいで、
あの…すごいこれだけはやってみたかったなっていう
裏メニューがあったんでやってみました
こちら！
です…
プリンを頼んで、
牛丼の上にプリンを乗せるとできるらしいです
なんかネットだと美味しいみたいな事が
書かれてたんで実際にやってみました
あの～…
はい、という訳でいかがだったでしょうか、
まぁ、裏メニューっていうのは
ちゃんと存在はするはするんですけども、
ネットに言われてるほど沢山無かっt…
しょうが丼とかも無かったし、
まぁ、ただ実際にすき家のトッピングとかね、
なんか、頼み方次第で出来ますよ
っていうのが沢山あったよっていうお話でした
うわぁもっとなぁ！
もっとなんかこう
ヤベェ裏メニューとかあったら
すごいテンション上がったんですけどもぉ、
まぁ、けどなんかちょっとスッキリはしましたね
とりあえず…
ラーメン食いてぇ！